- If I could switch wine cellars
with any player in a one-
on-one game, I would switch with—
- Take a little sip on that one.
- I got to take a sip on that one.
Who do you think's got a
better wine cellar: JJ [Redick] or Jimmy Butler?
- Jimmy Butler has the most
diversity in his cellar.
I'm not going to
beat him one-on-one,
but if I could...
We are here on Full-Bodied
today with the pride and joy
of the Lehigh Mountain
Hawks; the man, the myth,
the legend of the
Portland Trail Blazers;
the skills and drills
master, CJ McCollum.
Thank you again for
coming in and having
a glass or glasses with us.
So all three of these wines
meant something not only to me
in my story to you, but
I felt like in relation
to your story, your life story.
Let's start with
your wine first.
You know how the game is a
business. At the same time, how
have you dealt with
not only trade rumors,
but maybe sometimes not
always getting the credit you have
deserved for evolving your game?
- To start with development, it's
just been the story of my life.
Just work hard, work
for what you want
and kind of continue to
have to prove yourself
over and over again.
As I continued to work
and finally got a chance,
I just didn't want to blow it.
And I think throughout
the course of my career,
I've had to kind of reinvent
myself and kind of prove myself
each year.
Prove my consistency, prove I
can score first at this level,
then prove I can be a
facilitator at this level.
And I think eight years later,
five years as a starter, Dame
and I have been able to make the
playoffs seven straight years.
We've been able
to coexist, we've
been able to thrive together,
empower each other, and my game
has evolved to the
point where this year,
and obviously before I got hurt,
I was shooting 10,
11 threes a game, hitting
four or five threes a night.
I was averaging five assists.
I was helping lead
our team in a lot
of different
statistical categories
but also from a
leadership standpoint.
- You were balling,
now. You was different.
Let me give you
credit because you've
taken your role
of leadership. I'm
like, dang, like, this dude is
taking it to the next level.
Something to correlate
that to your wine,
I think to have the opportunity
to be in this business
and to not only put your
signature on your wine
but to make sure that you're
trying to get better at it
every single day is
ridiculously tight,
and I'm pretty excited to be
in this business with you.
If you had to play somebody one-
on-one for their wine cellar,
who would it be?
- Ooh. Hmm.
- You got to take a
little sip on that one.
- I got to take a sip on that one.
If I could switch wine cellars
with any player in a one-
on-one game, I
would switch with—
who do you think’s got
a better wine cellar?
JJ or Jimmy Butler?
- Jimmy Butler has the most
diversity in his cellar.
I'm not going to beat him one-
on-one, but if I could—right?—
I would get his cellar.
I like somebody where you could
say what part of the world
do you want to go to?
Do you have a Riesling
in your cellar?
Do you have a Chilean
wine in your cellar?
Do you have some New Worlds,
you know, Sonoma Coast?
Do you have some Walla Walla
Merlot or some Red Mountain
Cabernet from Washington.
So that is what I like.
Like, wine is so vast.
- That's why I mentioned
Jimmy because I
know he's well-versed in
traveling throughout Europe
and being in France.
- Oh, for sure.
- Being in some of these
areas, so he would bring me,
he would expose me to some
things I haven't tasted.
Like, Melo loves white Burgundy.
JJ loves white Burgundy.
They got a nice
mixture of things
that I wouldn't normally
have in my rotation.
- Describe these players
with specifically
the bottle or varietal of wine.
- Wow.
- So we're going to
start with LeBron.
- Wow, man. He's like, I
mean, what would you want?
American? You want Burgundy?
- No, no, no.
Worldly. Worldly.
We can go all over the world.
I'm with you.
- You know, you got Bron,
who’s arguably the best
player to ever play the game.
So, like, depending on what
your favorite wine is that exists,
I mean, he's a
Chateau Margaux, man,
in terms of what I would
drink. He was great early.
You know, he was deemed The
Chosen One, and he's
been able to kind of extend his
career 18 years later to where
he's sharper.
He's a better jump-shooter
than he was when he first
got into the league.
Still able to empower his
teammates, still able to make
his team win and still—
depending on who you argue with—
is still the best
player in the NBA.
So I think from a
price-point standpoint,
you looked at Top Shot, you see
how he's moving the needle.
- Oh, yeah.
- Trading cards,
everything in that realm,
and then it's impact
off the court.
I think you look
at wines and what
they've been able
to do for people,
you talked about bringing
families together,
being able to gift
people wines, share
wines with certain people.
I think he's done the same
thing with his platform.
He's shared to
communities, he shared
to the kids that come
from where we come from.
So I would say he's top-shelf.
He's the type of wine that
you know your wife won't
touch while you're out of town.
- All right, so how
about I'm going
to go to young
fella LaMelo Ball.
- LaMelo Ball, he is probably,
I mean, definitely New World.
- OK. OK.
He's so young, you
know what I mean.
He's got potential to be like
Opus, you know what I mean.
- Ooh.
- Yeah, I said it. He's
got the potential
to be Opus. The ceiling is very,
very high, a lot of upside.
I would definitely say the
acidity levels are high.
- [Laughing]
- You know, the game is like,
it leaves you like “wow.”
He's ahead of his time
from a vision standpoint.
When Mike [Jordan] is
saying that he's better
than we thought, you know you're
doing what you supposed to do.
- Let's go to the next one, right?
And I think the next
one would be my wine.
You are really good at a lot
of things outside of basketball,
whether you're the vice
president of the NBPA, whether you're
doing stuff when it comes
to Bitcoin and NFTs,
whether you're doing the
mental health, whether you're
doing a show.
So how do you do that?
Like, how do you find
time for all these things,
and what is your motivation
to being like that?
Is there a question to
kids who are 14 or 15
where people tell them
just stick to basketball?
- Basketball has
always been an escape,
and I've always wanted
to use the game.
I think a lot of times we allow
the game to use us, right?
You know, we put our
heart and soul into it.
We don't really have plans on
what we're like
outside of basketball.
We have no identity outside
of basketball, and then
when it stops, we struggle.
We struggle financially
or we struggle mentally.
We struggle physically
from an exercise standpoint
because we've depended on sport
for so long. We have nothing.
Being a guy who didn't
have a lot of scholarships,
was able to go to a school
like Lehigh, get a degree and pursue
a career in journalism,
I just wanted to make sure
that I had everything in place
outside of basketball as well.
- Right, totally.
- Basketball has
always been my Plan A,
but my Plan A involved
using basketball
to get Plan B: podcast. Plan C:
sharpen up my college degree
from a journalism standpoint.
Part D: make sure I'm exposing
myself to different avenues
so that I have different
streams of income.
I think for the
14- or 15-year-old
that's listening
to this, people are
going to tell you a lot
of things aren't possible.
They're going to tell
you a lot of things
can't happen to you because
it didn't happen for them.
- Let's go to that last
wine. That's Alexana.
You know, journeys have
to begin somewhere,
and this summer actually
I had a chance to come here.
Because some people
can make wine,
but there's other people that
put passion inside their wine,
which makes it taste better.
And so I liken this to you as
like they just don't do wine
from the Willamette
Valley. They do
a little wine from Argentina,
they do some stuff from Napa,
they make a Riesling,
which is next level here.
But you, you do different things
at a top level, and one thing
that's new that I try to explain
to people is the NBA Top Shot.
And so from your perspective,
where is that going?
How is that evolving?
- People are starting
to learn more about it,
the highlight factor, and
I would have likened it
to...it's similar to
the trading card
industry in which the
quantity kind of determines
the quality a lot of times.
This is a LeBron
dunk on Jason Terry.
Do they only make
five of them, or do they
make 20 of them?
Yeah, like that
was an iconic play.
It was like a once-in-a-lifetime
situation to which if Top
Shot puts that out, I bet you
they probably only put 23 out.
For one, because he's
number 23, and for two,
because it's an iconic moment,
and that kind of drives
the market value.
But I think Top
Shot is the future.
I think NFT is the
future, and being
able to have a collection
that you can store online that
can be safe and encrypted
is much easier
than me trying to remember
trading cards that I had
when I was [inaudible] years old.
So I think this new space of
being able to store things
online in general is the way.
I think NFT is the
future when you
find the right
products to buy, and I
think Top Shot is smart
for capitalizing on sports.
It sucks that I have to
pay for my own moments.
- [Laughing]
- You know what I mean? Like, I'm
trying to buy, like, my moment.
Like, my pull-up,
which is crazy.
- So we wanted to do a
small little game, right?
And those have been
already poured.
- I'm ain’t gonna lie to you, I'm
not very good at these games.
- That's all right. It’s taped.
- I will tell you that I did a
blind tasting with Melo,
and he had the year down.
We actually went to Alexana,
and he was getting the years.
- Oh, was he?
- One of these isn't from
Oregon or two of them
aren’t from Oregon?
- Well, you got to figure it out.
- This one is not from
Oregon for sure.
- I know what I just had
is definitely a Pinot.
- This is not from here.
I don't know where it's from,
but it isn’t from here.
- You know what's crazy,
I can almost tell you.
Oh, no, it's definitely
not a Pinot.
Oh. This is the Oregon Pinot.
Wow, that has a lot
of talents, but I still
don't think it's old world wine.
- Did you do the swish?
- Oh, yeah. you have
to do the swish.
You got to feel that
grip on the teeth.
I'm just going to say
that is the Oregon
Pinot right there, right?
Like Oregon--
- This is from somewhere else.
This is from another country.
- Yeah, yeah. This one's
definitely from another country.
We all agreed that the
second one is a Pinot.
One of them is not from America,
and the other one has to be—
- I think one of them might be a Cab?
- You know what, yes.
- Let me check the bottles.
- Yeah, what do we got?
- We got a Revana,
which is Napa, and then
we got Alexana Pinot.
- I should have known that.
I appreciate your time.
This has been great.
Thank you for being on Full-Bodied.
- Thank you for having me on, man.
I just want to say as a Black
man who’s entering the wine space
continue to break
barriers and continue
to enjoy all the hard work you
put it on and off the court
and continue to be that
celebrity that you are.
- Cheers to that, big dog.